- All right, let's wrap up
with something trending on the internet
you may have missed,
this is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
It's not easy being a mama of young kids
and moving to a new city,
so when Haley relocated
from Houston to Fort Worth,
she decided to form connections
by launching a little Facebook group
she called "The Weird Moms Club."
She thought she'd make
maybe a few friends.
That was five years ago.
Now she's got a whole
community around her.
The group has thousands of members
and has even become a
not-for-profit, which is incredible.
Let's say hi to Haley watching
on NBC 5 Dallas-Fort Worth.
What's up, Haley?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
Hi, hi, hi.
- [Kelly] What's up, girl?
- This is so surreal.
- [Kelly] Oh, it's nice
to have a Texan on.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- Yeah, absolutely.
How'd you get this started?
- Well, like you mentioned, I relocated
from Houston to Fort
Worth about five years ago
and my husband is from Fort Worth.
This is his hometown.
And so, he had all the
friends and the family
and the connections, and
they're great people,
but they weren't my people.
- Yeah.
- I was a working mom, still am.
My kids were a lot younger at the time,
they were two and seven.
And so, it was really
hard for me to get out
and make those connections for myself.
So, I ended up joining a book club
and hit it off with another mom here,
and we joked like,
"We're not regular moms,
we're weird moms," you know,
'cause we have piercings
and we don't like wine.
We like whiskey.
- We don't like wine.
- We don't fit that
stereotypical mom mold.
And we were joking around
and I said, "There's gotta
be more moms like us, right?"
Especially here in Fort Worth.
Created the Facebook group
and it's been five years
and now we have over 2000 members.
- So, explain how it's a nonprofit.
- Well, the nonprofit, so
in the 2000 plus members
we have now in "Weird Moms,"
I was really lucky to be
able to find a group of women
that I can depend on and
call them my framily.
And so, we started swapping
clothes amongst ourselves
for our kids and ourselves.
We kind of opened it up to weird moms.
And so, we went from
swapping with like 10 people
to a thousand people.
And then we were able to
incorporate, found the nonprofit,
and really open it up to the community.
So since April we've
distributed over 4,000 pounds
of clothes at no charge
to almost 800 shoppers here in the area.
(audience clapping)
- That is so cool.
Girl, I was that kid
who grew up in church.
Like they'd have like, they'd
collect bags of clothes
that, you know, hand me downs.
- Exactly.
- I grew up on all that, so that's so cool
because it's embarrassing for kids
to show up in the same outfit every day
and not everybody has that money.
And especially when you have a lot of kids
in your household, that's a lot of money.
So, that's so cool what you're doing.
It's got a really big
impact on those kids' lives
at school too, socially speaking.
So thank you.
That's so cool.
- Definitely.
- Haley, I'm liking your right now.
(audience clapping)
All right, well that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
bringing people together
just like you, so they're
gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
That should help.
- [Haley] I am speechless, thank you.
- Thank you so much from
one weird mom to another.
Thank you to all our
guests, Michael Buble,
Alexa and Harry Byrd.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.